i
[Música]
se cumplen seis meses del golpe de
estado en mi alma el gobernante militar
mina online inym prometió nuevamente
elecciones multipartidistas y asumió el
rol de primer ministro de un nuevo
gobierno interino los ministros de
relaciones exteriores de la asean se
reunirán mañana para decidir quién será
el enviado especial encargado para
facilitar el diálogo
los mexicanos votan en la primera
consulta popular a nivel federal
promovida por el presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador se necesita la
participación del 40% de la lista
nominal de los electores es decir unos
37 millones de personas para que el
resultado de esta consulta popular sea
vinculante
en tokio el venezolano daniel dhers
conquistó la medalla de plata en el
ciclismo bmx freestyle y la
estadounidense simon varios estará
ausente en la final de gimnasia de suelo
solo le queda una sola oportunidad de
competir en tokio la barra de equilibrio
tenemos detalles desde la capital
japonesa
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 cierre a blanco y
como siempre un gusto acompañarlos
cuando se cumplen seis meses del golpe
de sabe en mianmar el líder de la junta
militar gobernante mina online prometió
nuevamente elecciones multipartidistas
así como colaborar con una asociación de
naciones del sudeste asiático asean
además asumió el rol de primer ministro
de un gobierno interino a continuación
un recuento de lo ocurrido en ese país
en mianmar
primero de febrero en mianmar los
militares salieron a la calle y
detuvieron a un sand succi y sus aliados
acabaron así de manera abrupta con el
corto experimento democrático que llegó
tras 50 años de gobierno militar los
militares alegaron fraude en las
elecciones de noviembre de 2020 en las
que el partido de suu kyi la liga
nacional por la democracia consiguió una
amplia victoria el golpe tuvo un pronto
rechazo internacional y el ejército
birmano debería abandonar el poder que
ha tomado liberar a los abogados
activistas y oficiales que han detenido
levantar las restricciones a las
telecomunicaciones y abandonar la
violencia
balas
la resistencia comenzó con cacerolazos
pero con el paso de los días salió a las
calles en las semanas siguientes miles
de personas se manifestaron por todo el
país los gritos y las llamadas a la
liberación de succi fueron respondidos
con fuego real y fuerte represión por
parte del ejército 2 el décimo día de
febrero una joven de 19 años murió de un
disparo en la cabeza y su rostro se
convirtió en el símbolo contra la
violencia de la junta militar la onu
hablaba ya de crímenes contra la
humanidad el 27 de marzo murieron más de
100 civiles en abril un grupo de
legisladores en la clandestinidad
anunció la creación de un gobierno de
unidad nacional que llamaba a la
liberación de los presos políticos el 24
de mayo succi apareció por primera vez
desde su arresto debía comparecer por
diversas acusaciones hechas tras el
golpe que sus seguidores consideran
falsas para entonces diversas
asociaciones calculaban casi 800 civiles
muertos en el transcurso de los meses
numerosos grupos rebeldes étnicos se
opusieron a la junta militar contra la
que siguen luchando las calles se siguen
viendo algunas protestas mucho más
pequeñas en número
que aquellas de principios de año
hoy 1º de agosto se realiza en mexico en
la primera consulta popular a nivel
federal promovida por el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador en un
principio buscaba que la población
dijera si estaba de acuerdo en someter a
juicio a expresidente sin embargo tras
una revisión de la suprema corte de
justicia la pregunta original de la
consulta fue modificada al considerar
que violaba el principio de presunción
de inocencia conectamos con nuestro
corresponsal en la capital mexicana
mario carbonell mario muy buen día
explícanos el porqué de la controversia
de esta consulta
así es pues como lo has planteado en un
inicio el presidente quería que la gente
decidiera si se debe enjuiciar a los
expresidentes es ahí cuando surgió la
controversia pues los críticos
argumentaban que la justicia no se
somete a consulta y que la ley se debe
aplicar si existen delitos que perseguir
independientemente de la opinión de la
ciudadanía tras la modificación de la
suprema corte a la redacción de la
pregunta
presidente y más que el presidente de
los partidarios de él legisladores
simpatizantes promovieron hasta el
último momento la idea entre la
población de que se trata de saber si se
enjuicia a expresidentes y también esta
promoción pues fue acompañada de
imágenes de los ex mandatarios desde
carlos salinas hasta ernesto zedillo y
enrique peña nieto- esto provocó la
polémica principalmente mario que
permitiría esta consulta en caso de ser
aprobada y qué pasa si es aprobada pero
no con una participación suficiente para
que sea vinculante
definitivamente necesita participar
alrededor 37 millones de mexicanos para
que sea vinculante pero vinculante para
quien es el presidente de la suprema
corte ha aclarado que no derivaría
ningún momento en procesos judiciales
pero si en la posible creación de
comisiones de la verdad esto tendría que
llevarlas a cabo el poder legislativo y
el poder ejecutivo para conocer qué fue
lo que ocurrió y aplicar mecanismos de
justicia transicional es decir
reparación del daño y garantías de no
repetición esto sin duda pues es un
ejercicio inédito que independientemente
de que sea vinculante o no ya es algo
histórico y el partido del presidente
los legisladores han dicho que llevarán
a cabo estas comisiones de la verdad
-mario gracias por toda la información
feliz resto de día en francia alrededor
de 200.000 personas volvieron a tomarse
las calles de parís y otras ciudades
para manifestarse de manera pacífica
pero con algunos choques contra la
extensión del pase sanitario que será
utilizado para permitir el ingreso a
lugares públicos o como
o restaurantes también salieron para
protestar contra la vacunación
obligatoria para el personal de salud
más manifestaciones similares fueron
vistas en otros países en contra de las
restricciones por la pandemia de kobe 19
como en suiza italia e israel veamos
protestas en tel aviv en rechazo a las
renovadas restricciones israel ha vuelto
a imponer la obligatoriedad de las
máscaras en interiores y una vez más
exige su llamado pase verde para todos
los lugares con más de 100 personas ya
que la variante delta más contagiosa
está impulsando un aumento de caso casi
al 60% de la población está
completamente vacunado pero
aproximadamente un millón de israelíes
todavía se niegan a recibir la inyección
el pueblo de israel y el pueblo del
mundo tienen su soberanía y ellos son
los que deciden si quieren recibir algún
tratamiento médico en su cuerpo sabemos
que en todas partes la gente está
marchando estamos haciendo lo mismo
estamos unidos gritando libertad los
manifestantes suizos tomaron las calles
en ginebra- y lucerna repudiando las
restricciones del país y el certificado
job y escenas similares se vieron en la
vecina italia en milán cientos de
personas también marcharon contra el
pase verde de ese país un documento que
muestra prueba de vacunación resultado
negativo de tesco bit o recuperación de
un contagio reciente y a partir del 6 de
agosto se requerirá para ingresar
mayoría de los lugares incluidos los
cines y el interior de los restaurantes
esto en medio de la rápida propagación
de la variante delta que ahora
representa casi el 95% de los casos en
italia según el instituto nacional de
salud del país
el pase verde no es más que una
herramienta de chantaje para intentar
aumentar el número de personas obligadas
a vacunar sin embargo las protestas
fueron disueltas sensible más de 1.000
policías fueron enviados a la ciudad más
grande de australia para evitar
manifestaciones después de que miles se
manifestaran contra el cierre de esa
localidad la semana pasada
y vamos con información de los juegos
olímpicos de toque el venezolano daniel
dhers conquistó la medalla de plata en
el ciclismo bmx freestyle una prueba que
debutó en estas justas entre tanto la
estadounidense simon varios estará
ausente en la final de gimnasia del
suelo tras haber renunciado también a
las finales de salto y barras
asimétricas por lo que le queda solo una
oportunidad de competir en tokio la
barra de equilibrio nuestra enviada
especial natalia ruiz es con más
noticias desde la capital japonesa
rebeca andrade es la gran sensación de
la gimnasia artística aquí en tokio 2020
la brasileña de 22 años consiguió el oro
en la final del salto con otro fue más
que la esquina de la estadounidense
quien está sustituyendo a simón varios
quien se quedó con la medalla de plata y
jonas de korea consiguió el bronce
andrade que consigue este su segunda
medalla porque se había quedado con la
plata en el ejercicio completo en tenis
el alemán alexander sobre de es el nuevo
campeón olímpico tras vencer a heart en
hsia nobel al ruso en 6 361
y por último pues hoy fue ya las últimas
competiciones de natación aquí en el
tokyo y bueno se dos nadadores se
consolidaron por una parte de la
australiana en anda con quien consiguió
un total de siete medallas cuatro de
ellas en oro y calibres el del
estadounidense de 24 años quien
consiguió cinco medallas doradas
y esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france 24 continúen con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias buen día
[Música]